you can actually just get him you
control him essentially by sending
interesting videos and you could just
see his mind
he's gonna do research on that because I
kept sending him videos of bears because
he claimed
that a lion would beat a bear because
I'd love to get your take on this okay
so the bear is much bigger much stronger
but his take is that the Bears don't
have experience of fighting to the death
that's not part of the culture they're
more scared in fact he keeps sending me
footage of like even like a small
mountain lion scaring a bear away
because they're they don't want to fight
uh
so his idea is that it really matters
your life experience how much you fight
it's not necessarily the skill
um like the dimensions the the
characteristics you have
uh but then I send them I'll show you
people should
um Google this it's bears fighting of
any kind and it's it's pretty much the
most epic thing ever
here I'll show you
like look at these guys the cardio
though is interesting you know it's
funny I was going to mention that
because I was you know flipping to
internet I came I came
around that view look how big these guys
are no they huge but see they don't buy
each other
you think it's just playing they're
trying to no intimidating because they
don't want to get hurt
so they try to size each other up you
know they they'll see the whole fighting
is sizing each other up there's a lot of
pushing and the the the fur is so thick
so the cloth doesn't really damage much
and they're using the tree so maybe they
they yeah they're I mean there is bites
but see there's barely little
so the whole time they trying to
intimidate the other one like winning
the fight by the size
and mostly about like the way drunk
college kids fight which is like some
kind of display of dominance versus
actual yeah they're not fighting to kill
and bear or tiger you know they they
fight to Finish unless the odd one runs
away like one will die
yeah the lines and text yeah I uh well
look at the cardio look how bad the
cardio is I wonder how
uh my favorite part is when one of them
just like stands behind a tree it says
all right he's holding me
let me catch my breath he sits down it's
like all right you can't it's over
it's like uh it's the equivalent in the
in the in the forest tapping out all
right all right you got me yeah look
they're both like uh just shot
and but see the thing is that I was
trying to make an argument for is that
we get this rare footage it's not rare I
mean there's like hundreds of videos but
it's not millions of videos because
there's a huge number of bears and I was
trying to say that there's some badass
bear we don't know about
because he just goes in there
and just does work
and we just don't know about it because
he's
like ever see the thing is if you kill a
lot of other animals you probably have a
territory that nobody's gonna mess with
you so it's very hard to catch the uh
the
like the Hydra Gracie of bears you know
he's just gonna be sitting there doing
nothing so I don't know I don't know I
feel like
of course when you Corner him John will
say that if you put a bear and a line in
a cage the bear will win if it's like if
it's the if if they're forced to be to
the death but
I don't know